that's on perfect I listen to it that's
going to be a song that's being going to
be played at every wedding starting once
it's out ya have to replace thinking out
loud
yeah in both the boot it is so beautiful
and was that written for Cherry as well
yes did you think it or the first first
time or as cheesy as well I don't know
I'm not that so had it so you just put
it on the album if she heard it for the
first time
no she heard it like that was the first
time I completed to the album so she
heard it like early early days the weird
thing about that song is that there's a
line in it where I say with effort on
the grounds that grass listening to our
favorite song the song that we're
listening to his futures March Madness
which is like the least romantic sort of
us so we're in we're in obesity Oh James
get out and they for some reason there's
a certain point in the night and people
just put on house music and like I just
don't like house music you know a school
and I mean so yeah I changed it to
futures March Madness and they're just
like the four year old people being like
what are you doing what's this and then
we just had it done it's a beautiful
song it's absolutely gorgeous and I just
read your article on British GQ you look
hot on the cover very nice I think I
look Rick Jim feel like oh it was very
cute thank you you do it look good and I
was like oh it's really cute well no
they did another one where like I've got
like it's like black and white and we
got like a jacket and they look really
slow and I thought they were going to
use that one so yeah yeah that's things
like they have to buy the magazine again
it's really nice but you're very honest
about it you're honest about your
thoughts on your music and the way you
want to build your life and you said
Taylor Swift and yourself want to be the
biggest stars in the world honey I
understand anyone that doesn't think
like if you like I understand if you if
you want to write songs and keeping to
yourself and not playing to anyone like
do your thing that's that's given you
write songs make yourself feel better
but with you if you're like if you want
to sign to a major record label and work
and have an album out like why wouldn't
you want it to be it blows my mind that
it's such a bad thing to say I want to
be the biggest in the world because like
you don't you don't put out an album for
two people to hear you want the whole
world to hear the thing that you'll that
you're proud of and
so many artists we kind of like do
interviews and they're like a high you
know I don't care people buy my musical
notes like why why I find to a major
record label why do the interview like
why bother promoting it if you don't
want people to hear it and I spoke out
about it and got shot down and
apparently you're not meant to talk
about it but I think it how did you get
shut down because of your fans or he
said to me interview how would you feel
if people copied you and I said I don't
mind if people copy me and then the
quote was legend says people copy me and
then that gets blown up and everyone's
like really big kid like yeah it's one
of those ones where you thought you
can't win you can't I I'd like to think
that I'm a good-hearted person I like to
think people believe that but if they
can just judge me off one line in an
article then they're not really worth
knowing
I'm glad you cleared that up because
there was a lot of people who responded
in a negative way of what you were
saying but yet I thought it was really
honest and I felt great that you said
that it's not weird for a rapper to say
right now a rapper like it's very common
to any rap be like I am the greatest
rapper of all time
and that's something that everyone
should aspire to be but everyone should
be like I want to be the greatest and
I'm gonna make and you like in any field
that you're in like kids kids should be
encouraged you shouldn't be encouraged
to be ashamed of your dreams or things
of like how big you want to be if you
want to be a doctor going to be a doctor
you can't be like oh well maybe you know
I might go to MIT you have just be like
I will be a doctor you want to be in a
band I will become a doctor and I will
be the best doctor I don't know I don't
know why that's such a bad thing so
what's your definition then of being the
best well there's a difference there's a
difference between being the biggest and
being the best I think personally with
my music that I make I'm very very happy
with it so in my mind is the best it can
be
but the biggest once music's done is
just working hard like doing more
interviews and everyone doing more tools
and everyone doing bigger gigs and
everyone selling more records and have
everyone and that's that that's that's
something that you should want to do a
few times so major record label I think
and also in the article you say that you
and Taylor take it a bit too far what do
you mean by that
what we do we do
more promo than everyone without you're
not meant okay you know when sir you not
meant to do that much we take it too far
because we're really proud of our work I
didn't I didn't mean it in like a weird
way I just meant we like go above and
beyond to make sure people hear our
music and laughing I'm talking for her
anyway but yes I that's that's how I
feel she would feel about it
I haven't actually spoken to in depth
about this